[Music]
in nazi dog news nazi dog submitted by a
iran iran ee the the guy who taught his
dog how to do the nazi salute is now
having trouble getting work that's a guy
that came out in the news back when
pewdiepie on trouble right yeah way this
dog like looked at a video then he like
raises paw at a hitler video or
something you can't even teach your dog
the nazis food yeah that that sounds
like just troll ish it doesn't sound
like a straight real skinhead will get
his i don't know if it's a chihuahua we
should prevent the dog from getting a
job not the guy doggy no don't don't
hate me but it sounds kind of cute I
don't think there's any way I think it's
[ __ ] cutie [ __ ] wouldn't that dog
doing the Nazi salute if I'm a white
supremacist Nazi guy wouldn't I be
offended that my dog is doing mine
kick-ass salute you know saying it's
like hey that's a mockery to my [ __ ]
salute having a [ __ ] animal do it you
know me oh yeah like they don't have
permission yeah yeah yeah it's like
you're appropriating my salute this
videos gonna be great so what's going on
what kind of dog is the black laughs oh
my god it's so small as pause I have a
feeling that this is this is kind of
like a troll like a guy that doesn't
give a [ __ ] he's just doing funny [ __ ] I
highly doubt it's a Nazi so he's not a
racist so he claims so there is mark
he's 29 years old from the UK and he
made this video he puts it up on YouTube
and it went viral so he was just saying
that he wants to make his girlfriend
angry and so what she did is that she he
got to train her dog her puzzle to Steve
to me yeah it's a great idea
to them so he got this pug named Buddha
to do the cig hell yeah that he's like
honey or does he [ __ ] not see this
guy's a genius but no one would ever
know this dogs a huge balls name is
Buddha
yeah I told you it looks like a STONER
is always running raving about how cute
we go guys what are you saying
[Music]
a Nazi do i gas the jews do i gas the
jews do I catch the juice what a - puppy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he can be kind I'm not anxious by the
way I just really really wanted to pass
hot off yes is it right yeah I guess
that's the point of like it's an
insensitive joke to most people so oh
that's too bad
oh isn't that sad I feel like the only
people that can't speak up and get
pissed about this are Jewish people from
that time or even Germans I feel like
they have maybe dead Germans from that
time that experienced all the hardships
other than that
shut the [ __ ] up anyone can get up and
feel pissed about it we just don't have
to care yeah like that's my thing it's
like go ahead be as offended as you want
yeah but what's the offense like I think
it might be a little more touchy if he
was teaching his girlfriend's daughter
puppy yeah cuz no one's gonna really
know like it's not something he's doing
that he's gonna god I'm just like like
this this is like when I was we were
playing The Sims and my brother made my
character gay because he vited my
character over to his characters place
and he made them like gay do gay [ __ ]
and then when I give me you mean you can
make out yeah yeah exactly so it's right
so he made him like he made my character
make out with his character right and so
when I log into my character and I see
his love status thing it says that he's
like in love with the dude's character
and I was like you know this is like
when you like 13 years old me [ __ ]
you know you like what the [ __ ] moon
wood character gay and so then then I
invited his character over I filled the
entire room with wicker baskets I
deleted the doors and had a bunch of
chimneys in there and I burned him alive
character line which now it sounds
really terrible because I targeted and
killed a gay character in the sins is
what you kick is the [ __ ] headline
see if you're gonna go viral sure and
but for me the joke is that I killed my
brother's character because he [ __ ]
with my character that's what the bid is
see when you want to sensationalize
something like this you can do that
easily with anything yeah you burned a
gay character on sims alive and everyone
and you can just be like hey guys I'm
pranking my brother they don't listen to
that they just home I follow and then
that's this guy literally said right
after guys on that races I'm just trying
to [ __ ] around with my girlfriend her
sister I just try to piss her off they
didn't hear that they go he's a Nazi I
think the point is probably not that
he's a Nazi is just that he's making
jokes that people don't hear like Jared
if people were talking [ __ ] saying he's
a Nazi all that stuff right for sure
yeah they think he really is a Nazi
everyone's a Nazi half their offensive
everywhere everyone's a [ __ ] Nazi I
think there's very few Nazis I think
there's a lot of people that don't that
haven't grown up to realize what's
offensive yet and what's not we're all
learning now but I mean we're not learn
I don't think weird evolving now that's
true but true yeah I feel like it's if
you're if you can look in the camera and
say I am NOT racist I just I'll friend
is gonna get pissed off then obviously
he's in a relationship with someone
who's not racist right so he's probably
not racist too because well the dog's
name is Buddha
yeah that's that's a given already like
unless he made like the [ __ ] guy I
don't know one tooth Clancy like I don't
know you know and it's funny seeing a
dog looking at like wall Hitler's
talking and dogs like you idiots like a
roly poly lady looks interested he's
like whoa this is asking some good ideas
it's like and a dog thinks that Hitler
has good ideas is like nah it's nice
it's nice like what's wrong with that my
god and I didn't kill my character cuz
he was gay did I so there you go I
didn't kill my character who was gay
just to put it out there thank you I
loved him still yeah he rebuilt his
house after it burned down I think
that's kind of nice thank you so mark is
been going to court what for what for a
hate crime yes for committing a hate
crime gotta be kidding he's Irish right
he sounded Scottish Scottish okay he
looks like the antithesis of a [ __ ]
Nazi he looks like the opposite like he
looks like he he marches with an tyfa
and like hits bongo drums to be he
doesn't look like a neo-nazi to me but
to me if you march with an TV or a nazi
- yeah that's like the four left nazi
but yeah i mean he looks like the kind
of guy that like smokes weed and plays
bongo drums and like stands up for
women's rights and stuff it must be the
animal activists are the ones are really
mad maybe PETA
prolly yes so during their trial the
director of the Scottish Council of
Jewish communities he labeled the video
grossly offensive he said this quote I'm
no historian but it is the marching
signal of a Nazi storm troopers who
contributed and supported the murder of
six million Jew a juice including
members of my own family and I take this
slightly personal material of this kind
goes to normalize the anti-semitic views
that frankly we thought we had seen the
lasso the Holocaust is not a subject for
jocular content I thought it did the
opposite I thought what it did is make
fun of something that was once feared
and you Mel Brooks in jail springtime
for Hitler
how dare he Mel Brooks should go to
[ __ ] jail for what he did wait in the
name of comedy what did he do oh he did
you know the producers which is it
basically the they do a shitty play on
purpose because it's like they there was
a
make money or whatever and they do this
play called springtime for Hitler and
it's like good like Tirico it's a
teracle but like that's what I'm saying
like he's making light of a very serious
situation oh dear us like clutch my
pearls while I [ __ ] cry yeah and then
if you get somebody who was affected
like literally a victim of that time and
they say I personally was affected by
this because my family was involved then
we give them this crazy credibility like
through a [ __ ] king like they are
holding a scepter that says you live or
you're die I [ __ ] hate this [ __ ]
this is insane maybe cuz it's like I
don't know I'm so far away in California
and I'm Asian I wasn't born during that
time like I just don't I can't be
emotionally affected as much as maybe
someone who lives in the UK or Germany
during that time I don't know because
I'm trying to picture what I'm trying to
imagine right now just because I like to
be empathetic it's like what is
something that that that guy could have
done to offend me like maybe if he took
like I don't know like a chouchou and
you put it in overalls and he hadn't
build a railroad I don't know but you
would laugh exactly because you don't
have a stick up his [ __ ] on the same
level as Hitler I mean maybe if it was
something to do with like the cream war
or something you know there's got to be
something that's it okay well let's see
in the Korean War it's irrelevant to me
no matter look you can make fun of 9/11
for all I care go ahead there are real
people in America who were affected by
9/11 a lot of us would even argue that
we were affected by 9/11 I know I was
yeah right not never to a degree that a
real family member who lost someone was
but my god there are no sacred cows we
should not have this this [ __ ] where
it's like this guy was doing a joke what
was his intent it's irrelevant because I
was affected by this and he offended me
and that's all this is about I'm
offended I also think about like like I
would like time like timing timings
always you know important for comedy so
like if it's been like a hundred years
maybe we can make fun of the Romans now
without anyone being offended but if it
was just yesterday like nah haven't
happened then it's like maybe
people are alive that remember it no I'm
just I'm just I'm just exaggerating here
but like this is World War two
yeah oh that's that that's a to a lot of
people like even the stories say that
it's like there's like a certain amount
of like sensitivity I said there's like
this podcast I was like the geekiest
thing I ever listened to but it was just
literally only about history but he was
talking he was talking about how things
are tough lightly about depending on
time
yeah so we could make let's say somebody
make jokes about the Spartan Wars right
that was a very very you know people are
getting murdered be ahead and got it
[ __ ] in the ass whatever but because
overtime just a [ __ ] we're removed from
him as an uncle or cousin that died in
that war what becomes when something
becomes like so historically like in the
back it just then there's no like good
people aren't allowed a life order so
here's where this is going
there's a movie you remember you guys
have all seen the Avengers right yeah I
am of the same a victim of violence
there's so many victims of physical
violence there's a scene where the Hulk
after getting pumped up and beating a
bunch of [ __ ] up he's standing next to
Thor and then he punches Thor and
everyone in the movie theater that I was
in laughed at violence they laughed at
physical violence and I am a victim of
this that scene should be removed and
Joss Whedon should be tried tell me how
that's different than this [ __ ] it's not
to me it's not yeah it's not a crime
okay it's a fictional depiction of
violence just like he did a fictional
depiction of [ __ ] Hitler loved it's
absurd I mean there's a line there's a
line probably for most people and then
there's a line for the really loud
people so we're just hearing the the
line that's this new line that's drawn
really low for these really loud people
and that's all we hear about but I mean
was it insensitive and wrong I guess but
you know maybe but it's maybe cuz it's a
dog take serious but you it's a little
insensitive I mean you're not gonna go
home and train your dog to do some [ __ ]
like mine now
Suzanne with Buddha oh the Nazi dog I
know look at God he has no idea yes I
look happy can you imagine being a dog
you're behind all this controversy and
they're like humans are [ __ ] dumb
that dog I swear to God if that dog
walks away free I'm gonna be so pissed
ha ha that dog you look at him in the
eye he's saying Heil Hitler
thank you so that's different yeah he's
gonna try out and I'm a beanie on he's
laughing he should be missing looks like
the plug to know the girlfriend I was
saying that like anything that you did I
mean she knows who he is or she knows
that he's not a racist though didn't
affect her well he doesn't need to prove
to do anyone like I could he doesn't he
just I know I could smell racism like
there's no he doesn't seem like the kind
of guy that enjoys to draw swastikas on
the wall on a Saturday you know it looks
like he like [ __ ] like a skinny asian
girl with the [ __ ] spiked choke
collar kid he used to ride skateboards
in his early years and then he got a
little bit chunky and now he likes to
prank his girlfriend and like play video
games and you know smoke the occasional
ganja while he goes to the park with his
friends and talk that's the back story
yeah that's that's the kind of guy he is
is there a line for any of you where
someone should go to jail for something
mate for joke no I don't think anyone
should go to jail for the things that
they say I feel like the line for me
would just be if I did something to
someone else whether verbal or whatever
and then that person's life was ruined
like they they couldn't get work or
whatever and they're just a good person
in a victim's Weibull yeah yes you know
kind of true like if I made up some
crazy lie about you yeah and the world
bully
yeah and then you became like well I
can't get a job you know it was a joke
like if you made a joke about me but
then it stuck with me and then I could
never get work again or like I could
never get friends again or something I
mean when it actually ruins someone's
life I feel like but it's a joke
yeah but if it ruined my life and I
could never get work again well what's
the context of ruin in life and how
could you prove it I guess like the
being publicly shamed everywhere you go
like press following you making fun of
you
asking you like but usually just only
like if you became a mean yeah but one
not kind of like this guy now this guy
can't get work you can argue that kid
guy [ __ ] like hosed everywhere he
went and I think even Sudan want yeah he
did but like God that did that heal the
world oh yes it did the Star Wars came
out yeah good he did dry slain yeah he
made my heart so war me too he actually
started a trend of other people doing
lightsaber stuff on like like objects
yeah he started that trend you should be
proud of yourself and he was like one of
the first memes ever because everyone
like edited the video and did something
else with it
and a hundred percent bro like you're
doing that the world had to see it and
you know what you getting you am viral
yeah at the expense of your
embarrassment but at the end of the day
it's the result that matters
hey guys would you think of that video I
know you loved it so make sure to hit
that like button to watch more videos
check it out up here
[Music]